اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط
وجندي وينقل لواء المظليين من شمال القطاع
الى خانيونس جنوبا للانضمام الى القوات
المقاتله هناك وكتائب القسام تستهدف اليات
اسرائيليه في خانيونس وتعلن قتل وجرحى
اكثر من 20 جنديا في حين اكد مستشفى
اسرائيلي في عسقلان عالجه اكثر من
3 و500 جندي جريح منذ السابع من
اكتوبر تجدد الغارات الاسرائيليه على
مناطق عده وسط وجنوب قطاع غزه ووزاره
الصحه تعلن استشهاد 150 فلسطينيا في 12
مجزره اسرائيليه خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه
ليرتفع عدد الشهداء الى
822 منذ بدء
الحرب في ظل خلافات داخليه بشان سير الحرب
على غزه نتنياهو يقول ان القضاء على حماس
يجب ان يسبق الحديث عن ترتيبات ما بعد
الحرب ويشدد على ضروره سيطره اسرائيل على
محور فيلادلفيا ووزير خارجيته يقول ان
الحكومه مسؤوله عن هجوم السابع من اكتوبر
في حين دعا وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي الى
تشجيع ما وصفها بالهجره الطوعيه لسكان
قطاع غزه وايجاد دول مستعده
لاستقبالهم وفي الضفه الغربيه اصابه 15
فلسطينيا في قصف نفذته مسيره اسرائيليه
وفي مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال في طول كرم
واريحا ووثقت صور اعتداء قوات الاحتلال
على احد عمال محطه وقود جنوب الخليل بينما
قالت هيئه شؤون الاسرى ان عددا كبيرا من
اسرى سجن عوفر تعرضوا لحالات تسمم بسبب
تقديم وجبات طعام فاسده الى
اللقاء